alright everybody we are live and
joining me is former Google's senior
software engineer turned guy who shared
his opinions turned guy who was fired
for those opinions from google james
d'amour welcome to the rubin report
thanks it's great to be here I am I'm
looking forward to this to prove that
we're doing this live we were about to
go live about a minute ago and right
before we started he said to me should
the dog be in here should the dog be in
here my dog was was laying here but we
took the collar off while we let her go
so I appreciate that you have had a
crazy whirlwind of a month and I
mentioned to you when we were in the
green room that I asked you what the
exact day that you thought all this went
down you said August 5th which was right
when I was going off the grid so as I
was getting my phone out of hand when I
was gonna put it away and disappear I
saw your name I saw the story and I was
like man this is the type of guy that I
gotta talk to I should be all about this
story but then I disappeared so I'm glad
we're doing this
so let's say so let's start with this
first off how are you just as a human
being we're gonna get to your backstory
we're gonna get to the the ideological
echo-chamber the ab right here but how
are you as a human being right now I'm
doing okay I mean I wish I had a job but
you know it's not until you don't have
one that you realize the benefits of you
know having a job and going to work
every day
having a group of people that you hang
out with guys so you were fired do you
know the exact date August 7th is August
7 ish so this thing ruminated and banged
around for about three or four days or
so and then you were fired were you
absolutely shocked that you were fired
for writing this 10 page manifesto
that's the word that I see do you have a
what word would you prescribe to this
document that I'm holding here I've just
been calling a document you just
document yeah it's funny you said to me
before you said you know I sort of
something like I can't believe I'm in
this like I'm just some nerd and I guess
the way heard would describe a document
is just by document but were you
completely shocked at what happened here
yeah I I never really thought that it
would explode like this I I just wanted
to have a one-on-one conversation with
the diversity programs and you know
really discuss the issues but it never
really came to it okay so for the people
that don't know what this is about
obviously we're gonna get to that but
before anything else I thought it would
be important just to talk about your
biography a little bit just to to prove
you're a guy who knows what he's talking
about and you're a well-educated guy all
that so can you just take me through a
little bit of your history schooling
types of jobs you had and what your job
was at Google mm-hmm so I went to
University of Illinois for undergrad I
was doing science like biology physics
chemistry and then I didn't really know
what I want to do so I decided to
graduate early and then just work at MIT
for a year and that was a lot of fun
took some classes there and then I
decided to go to grad school so I went
to systems biology which is like
mathematical biology at Harvard and that
program was really great but so I went
there for about two years
it was the ph.d program and but while I
was there I got really into algorithms
and these little puzzle things so I did
a coding competition and Google found
out that I did well so they actually
just directly contacted me said that oh
yeah you should apply to Google so I
interned there and decided you know
Google is a great place yeah it's you
know probably the company that will
change the world and its benefits are
great so I was like okay this is a once
in a lifetime chance I'll just do it and
so I left the ph.d program to join
Google yeah and this is just a couple
years ago obviously you're a young guy
so you mentioned some I mean these are
big name schools MIT Harvard you are
educated educated in biology and you're
working with algorithms all these things
Google
you after you do this competition so
sort of to lay out how this whole thing
got written and why you did it first
you're working at Google for a while and
then they started sending you guys not
just you but people to diversity
training is that correct right okay so
can you explain what diversity training
is yeah it's kind of complicated because
there's multiple different programs but
it's often talking about how you know we
have 50% of people in the population or
women but at Google we only have 20% and
so they discuss all of the sexism that's
happening and how that's holding back
women in general and then they also have
stuff about racism and all these other
unconscious biases because you know we
don't really see anything like oh you're
a woman therefore you can't code there's
never these explicit forms of bias that
we see mm-hmm and so and we haven't
really been able to measure X like
actual bias at Google so we just assume
that there's some sort of low-level bias
that's happening mm-hmm and you know
it's always really impossible to measure
but so they these programs go over that
they go over microaggressions and white
male privilege and then discuss how we
can make the workplace better for women
and how we can get more women on our
teams basically yeah now you don't have
anything against women are you is
something I need to know James the more
thinks about women before we go any
further I definitely like women I I had
women on my team and I you know I
treated them well yeah I mean I discuss
a lot of these issues with them and they
actually largely agreed mm-hmm and they
helped me discuss you know okay on
average women are say more cooperative
and how can we change the workplace so
it's not just you know some alpha male
that owns a project and gets promoted
and it's actually people working in
teams and all of them getting recognized
yeah so it's interesting to me because I
actually have
small business here most of my jobs in
my life have been odd jobs or doing
stand-up things like that I've never
worked for a giant corporation like
Google before and it's funny because
when you talk about well 50% of the
population is female and Google only has
20% it's almost like well how is that an
issue for the average employee at Google
now the microaggressions and that other
stuff I can see why if you buy that that
stuff is legit if their HR people buy
that stuff legit I can see why they'd
sit down with employees and talk about
that but to talk about the 50% of women
in the population and we only have 20%
here isn't that something for HR to deal
with what does that have to do with
bringing in software engineers and
talking to them about that yeah I think
Google just has a long history of you
know the whole don't be evil and you
know we make a ton of money through ads
therefore we feel sort of guilty and we
have to help the world in general so we
do a lot of philanthropy and they're
really big on being allies for these
groups mm-hmm and just outreach in
general yeah if it makes you feel better
they're not making much money on us
because they don't monetize anything and
I can't our video I just told you before
we start our video from this morning
from this morning with Phil DeFranco who
has almost 6 million subscribers who's
one of the first YouTube creators around
was demonetized this morning right so
but I do want to talk to you a little
bit about algorithm but let's let's keep
going with you okay so you go to these
these meetings obviously you're having a
bit of an ideological difference in
terms of what you think versus what
they're pushing on you they asked for
your feedback right after these things
so can you tell me about that yes in all
of our meetings and programs in general
were usually very open and we asked for
feedback in how we can improve these and
so I I wrote this document because I
really wanted to put my thoughts down
and so I sent it to them and they looked
at it but they because it's a Google Doc
so I could actually see that they looked
at it and read through it but they just
never did anything and this happened
multiple times I went to multiple
programs and they just ignored it every
time yeah so to be clear when you say
programs so you sent it to a they have
several
diversity groups right so you sent it to
several different groups what are some
of the groups so one of them was about
on biasing and another was your journey
towards you know rethinking race so
those are several of them that I went to
and yeah there's yeah you saw that they
were open but you were dissing right so
so just to be clear you write this in
response because they want feedback
that's actually nice to hear the
companies want feedback I keep trying to
get them on the phone with me to discuss
some of the problems that I'm having
with YouTube that that seems to be kind
of difficult but you write this in
response which is sort of what they're
asking for they're asking for your
feedback now you are a scary white male
and you're tall so that's got to be
working against them do you do what they
want then you submit this to several of
these diversity groups who ignore you
then you submitted it to one particular
one and that's where this really took
off so so which one was that
yeah so after a month of actually
sending it to individual people and some
smaller email lists and actually getting
some good feedback that wasn't you know
this emotional outrage I that's
interesting let's not jump past that so
first you're you are getting some
feedback within the company then people
are basically yeah basically okay yeah I
have the people with beaches like yes I
agree totally and then the other half
would disagree on certain points and
they say oh are you sure that this is
happening and especially if your
progressive then you often don't even
see a progressive echo-chamber because
you just see oh yeah that's how things
should be mm-hmm and what's wrong with
all of this and oh are you sure that
people would actually be shamed for
saying these things you know and because
you think that that system or that
worldview is so complete or something
it's hard to a mad which is exactly what
an echo chamber is and so that was all
fine but then I was sent it to this one
email list called skeptics so I thought
you know skeptics would be rational and
I'd be able to point out holes in my
argument cuz honestly the whole time I
was just I want to be wrong because if
I'm right then there's something
right please tell me how I'm wrong and
that's not really what the response was
it was just this is crap what are you
doing and eventually just exploded
without it within the company yeah all
right so to be clear so the skeptic
group which is the group that should be
skeptical of all facts and opinions and
all that you send it to them but then
how within that so now you start getting
some feedback on how within that group
did this then get to the larger world
and that's when all hell broke loose
yeah so some of the people would start
sending emails to say my upper
management and HR demanding that I be
fired or something and so HR and some of
the higher level execs started sending
out masking emails saying oh yes we know
about this document don't worry you know
it's harmful don't look at it this is
not what Google stands for which
obviously you know if you tell someone
that this is harmful they're gonna just
look at it it's harmful don't look at it
that's what executives were saying I
mean that's it and also there were a ton
of memes within the company just talking
about you know how horrible this was and
just blasting me as a person now was
there any retribution on those people
we'll get to you actually getting fired
and called into the office but you as
far as everything that I read in this
document which I did read you didn't
attack anyone personally you go out of
your way not to stereotype people can
argue with you know your conclusions are
all that but you were being attacked
personally by people than within the
company where is there any retribution
from those onto those people no not that
I know of
there was even someone that email
directly saying you are a terrible
person
you're misogynist I'm going to hop like
hunt you down until you're fired
or I'm fired like to send this to HR I
don't care which means that maybe he
knows that HR isn't really going to do
anything yeah and so I sent it to HR but
so yeah it's an HR did they even respond
they said oh yeah work from home but I
told you to work from home yeah so just
I just I think it's so important to
repeat some of this stuff you wrote this
in response to being taken to a place
where they wanted your feedback
now they happen to not like coming back
okay then you were being threatened in a
way by other employee
and being attacked online with the memes
and all that stuff again while you're
still an employee they're an HR tells
you to work from home yeah and you have
no evidence that they contacted this
person at all I honestly don't know and
I mean there were many people that
started attacking me and it was mostly
public attacks because you know most
people aren't really courageous enough
to send me an email like that right and
they just want to show other people oh
look how great I am
I got offended by this and let's all
band together and punch Nazis Yeah right
virtually signalling yeah but yeah yeah
industry term for that okay so then now
you're beat you were being attacked
personally you're being told by HR to
stay home now did you get a call or an
email how did you end up in an office
where they said you're out of here buddy
I yes so I they eventually just called
me Monday night and said James you've
been terminated for perpetuating gender
stereotypes and then you know I tried to
discuss it with them but they didn't
have any of that they did this on the
phone yeah they didn't even have you
come into the office until you
face-to-face and they were probably
afraid that I would just you know have
some outbursts or something well you
seem very violent I mean I've never seen
a more soft-spoken
you know slim you know you don't strike
me as someone that's gonna hurt anybody
but even I mean the sort of cowardice of
that is is actually kind of incredible
so okay so then you get fired now this
is after it had gone public obviously so
the stories were all over the place at
this point did you try to plead your
case I mean did you say this is crazy I
was just doing naturally the same thing
that you're asking everyone else to do
you just don't happen to like my
opinions yeah I tried to but obviously
it didn't have any effect yeah is there
a legal issue there that you know about
I'm assuming every lawyer and their
cousin is out to talk to you these days
about yeah lawsuits and all that so I
even before they fired me I made a claim
to the National Labor Relations Board
because what this is is I was making a
concerted
effort with multiple others employees
that agreed with me to improve our
working conditions so your honor pointed
out multiple ways in which there was
harassment in the workplace and that
there was illegal discrimination in our
hiring practices can you give me an
example of it of the legal
discrimination yeah yes so as far as I
know and according to our internal
policies you can't use someone's
protected status so their age race or
gender when you're determining hiring or
other employment critical situations so
and but we do in these you know we treat
different candidates differently and
then if someone is going up for
promotion they may be treated
differently so there's a lot of small
things that we're doing they may be
treated differently in a positive way if
I are one of those protected is just
worth saying the full sentence because I
think people get people are so confused
by what's going on these days that
everything is upside down yeah so okay
so you contact them and then where are
you at in terms of any legal stuff right
now as much as you can tell me yet so
we've filed the claim and so they're
investigating right now and we are also
looking for other Googlers that have had
similar treatment and we've gotten
multiple responses for that so there
have been multiple cases in the past
where say someone and like I'm of course
for gay rights but someone just didn't
want to go to gay pride parade and they
got fired for that it's like that's a
little too literally true yeah so
someone at Google just said I don't want
to go to the gay pride parade yeah and
they got fired for that at least
according to them we have to look into
it more but and there have been multiple
cases like that where if you don't agree
with the progressive ideology then
you're then you're discriminated against
and there's any way you could also be
totally pro game just not want to go to
a parade yeah I'm not a huge parade guy
myself a big parade guy huh I enjoyed
the gay pride parade in San Francisco
but I can definitely tell it's not for
everyone
right right that's a bit of a sideway
there
all right so so all of this happens and
again the reason I started with how are
you as a person is that I know you know
I can't compare some of the things that
I've gone through over the last couple
years with what you've gone through
because you you were hit with a
landslide I've sort of had a more like
slow evolution into craziness you're
dealing with the media and craziness but
I know what it's like when people write
terrible things about you and deeply
dishonest things and call me a Nazi or
all right or you know just all that crap
right yeah so suddenly you're you're a
private citizen forever from everything
I can tell a pretty decent guy and now
the media there's blood what was that
like for you because I think that also
is a lot of you know I talk about the
culture of fear right now of why people
many people email me and they say well
I'm afraid to say this or I'm afraid to
post your video on Facebook or any of
this stuff and I think it's because
everyone fears this retribution yeah so
as someone that has gone through it in a
very high-profile way but you're still
here you're still here and even though
you said to me before you don't know
what you want to do next
you don't know if you want to be a
public person next we're any of this but
you made it to the other side you're
alive now and you're okay and you're
smiling so what can you say about that
yeah I think I realized that it was sort
of do-or-die
and because if I didn't say anything in
it I didn't defend myself then the media
would just keep pounding on oh this
bigoted guy said the sexist stuff and
you know I talked to Jordan Peterson
very early on and he told me yeah just
you know talk to the media because once
they I see that you're just a normal
person and you're not some crazy
aggressive women hater then you know
your case will just get better yeah your
public image at least do you sense that
that is work because you've done some
stuff so you did Jordan Peterson you did
Joe Rogan yesterday you've got some
mainstream yeah stuff right it's helped
I unfortunately it's often either the
center or the right will interview me
and I've tried to get long-form
interviews on the left and just no one
is biting yeah so and so people will
just complain saying oh yeah I'm just
pandering to the right
it's a no-win situation you know it's
incredible to me how much I see this
story repeated and repeated so Bret
Weinstein who I know you're familiar
with he was only asked to go on Fox News
Turner asked him to go on I'm going on
Tucker tonight I'm just saying it now
for the first time to discuss everything
that's going on with YouTube and I get
invited on Tucker and Greg Gutfeld and a
bunch of other things on Fox nobody
invites me from MSNBC I can't bash the
door down much much like you can so you
tried you did try to get on other yeah
I'm leaning out I mean I've given
interviews to CNN and Bloomberg Business
Insider and you know they were pretty
hostile interviews but at least I did do
them but it was often you know I would
do an hour-long interview and then they
would cut it down to five minutes of the
worst possible stuff I mean I still
don't think I I it was bad but did you
have anyone helping you with media
sensitivity training or anything it's
like right here I mean I I know you're
aware of the show and who I am and all
that and I don't have an agenda I truly
want to hear your story and that's it
but that when you go on these shows I
know for for me if I've learned anything
is that I would never do a show at this
point that's not live because I know the
way these people act and behave you know
did you at any training or did you gonna
old counsel with anyone you you just
really just went out there and did it
yeah I I'm usually a pretty independent
person so I don't like asking for help
really mm-hmm so I just did it learning
it as I go
yeah so then I saw on Twitter that you
were happy to take these interviews and
you did interviews with people all over
the place you were on stefan molyneux
now i've done his show a couple times I
have never had him here I've enjoyed the
conversations that I've had with him I
get a lot of hate for even talking to
the guy but then suddenly after that and
you were a member of the evil scary
altar right so I also saw you tweet out
that you are not part of the alt right
or that you you've said publicly you're
not part of the alt right how does that
even fit into this because I think
that's an interesting thing this is now
catch-all phrase of all right this but
the early Bazaar I mean I think it's
just another one of those labels that
the media has put on anyone that they
disagree with you know they were calling
Jordan Peterson all right they were
calling just everyone
all right and you know when you look at
it and you look at the definition like
and it's actually white nationalist or
white supremacists you can see that no
one like very few people are actually
white supremacist but they're just using
this broad brush to really label it's
too many people yeah and they're almost
making the tent bigger because every
time they call you alright or they call
me alright or Jordan Peterson well all
these people who like what we think
about things they're gonna wait a minute
that's what the alright is that it must
be pretty decent you know if the more
and Peterson are in there these guys
aren't bigots or racists or any of these
other things but you you now say that
you are not part of the alright or any
of that kind of stuff were you shocked
at even so did any of this shock you
that that's what I think is most
interesting here is like you obviously
have seen all this like pretty clear to
me but did you as someone that was going
through it did it shock you
it definitely shocked me I mean I knew
at least some of the lower level you
know political bias can shape how we
view the world but I never knew that it
was this widespread and the media
portrayal was so inaccurate and you know
I'm not necessarily a fan of Trump but I
can see what he's saying about you know
CNN being fake news because every one of
their articles about me would just be
this horrible stuff and people it was
really nice to see that all the comments
were you know CNN this is fake news did
you actually read it
some people are fighting back right and
then I'm sure they were deleting those
comments I didn't saw something when I
was doing a little research
a few people sent me something that you
you mentioned me in an in a reddit AMA
that I made so I quickly googled both
our names and then it came up I think I
can't swear to it I think it was a Think
Progress article basically implying
you're all right and then they quoted me
obviously it wasn't talking about you
something from months ago making it seem
like I was part of that too and it's
like you all liars and the more you lie
the more you're just putting water on
gremlins and you're spreading the the
very thing that you fear most which i
guess is probably good for people like
us but it's it's a little annoying so
let me ask you this hmm
I have your scary document here by the
way I flipped losing many times I don't
even get a paper cut so we're not we're
not dealing with that much here what
would you say is the most controversial
thing that you wrote in
is there is there one piece of this
thing that you could go well I guess
maybe that's the one or maybe I said
this wrong or or what's the thing that
people were most sensitive to so me
saying neuroticism which is just a
personality trait and that's the
official term that was a mistake maybe
because a lot of people are like oh he
said women are neurotic and that has a
ton I gave connotations mm-hmm and then
yeah just the whole of biology you know
ever whenever you mentioned biology
that's controversial when it comes to
differences between people okay so I'm
glad you mentioned that because I think
this might be the most important
important part of anything we're gonna
discuss right now and if people are
listening to this I think this may be
the key thing of all this it seems to me
that the social justice movement and
this hierarchy of oppression of the
oppression Olympics and the virtue
signaling it seems like it is in direct
conflict with biology which is why
they've been so against Richard Dawkins
a biologist it's why they've thrown
Brett Weinstein a biologist under the
bus it's why they've attacked you
someone who has studied biology under
the bus it seems to me that because
biology has nothing to do with what
they're talking about they're talking
about this sort of amorphous thing of
victimhood as virtue but that's not how
biology works it's not how evolution
works or anything else that it was it
had to get here do you think that's a
fair statement yeah and there are some
biological truths that you can't just
paint with oh this is just oppression
this is society like constructed
oppression and you know it's really hard
to just keep denying some things yeah so
what would be an example of that of a
simple biological truth that would be
against I mean at least you know
according to this it's just the link
between prenatal testosterone and some
masculine like behaviors and so you know
we've know that testosterone does affect
behavior and you know if you ask someone
that transitions you know as transgender
then they'll also tell you that yes
taking
hormone treatment right did it change me
in some ways and you know it's not good
or bad it's just different right and if
we were all the same wouldn't there be
then truly an equal amount of women in
the NBA as men I mean you wouldn't need
the WNBA right like even in women look
if let's say women less I mean I have no
idea but let's say women love basketball
as much as men do I suspect generally
speaking men like it more probably
getting us in trouble there I don't know
what the exact new study has shown on
men and women in basketball but why
would you have I mean there's obviously
biological differences otherwise you
would have women doing 360 dunks yeah
you know like LeBron James yeah physical
nicely and height is definitely
something that's well known and not that
controversial yeah and I I feel like if
a woman wanted to join the NBA they
should be able to sure but if one has
the skills that didn't complain the NBA
had a rule and said women cannot play in
this league I would have a problem with
that actually you know I believe any you
know it's equal opportunity they have
their own league which is sort of
separate but equal but also nobody
watches because it's not it's simply not
as good as the NBA Megan in I'm digging
into those people but I don't I don't
really care what they think so the
biology piece though how do you as
someone that cares about this how do you
navigate that I mean when you've seen
people like Dawkins and and Weinstein
treated the way they're treated how does
this conversation get cleaned up a
little bit if guys like that have so
much trouble navigating or will be
kicked out by those voices on the left
yeah it's really hard you have to just
find someone that's reasonable and have
a one-on-one discussion because if you
just have this you know huge public
thing then there's inevitably gonna be
someone calling you some bigot or racist
and yeah yeah I still don't really know
how to navigate the waters I'm maybe not
the best to ask yeah well you seem like
you're doing a fine job I mean you're
willing to to be part of this fight you
know we don't kind of we don't always
get the heroes we asked for we get
people that that are suddenly you know
either brave enough to write this and
again you were at
you you that's the irony here is I think
a certain amount of people will will
look at you or watch this and think oh
you know he just wanted to say something
controversial and get in profit from it
somehow or or get in the news or do
these shows or whatever it is when in
fact you did everything possible to play
by the rules that they had set up to
have your your voice heard yeah I
definitely never meant for this to
become huge and it was never my
intention to make it so big that I got
on this show although you know it's
obviously great to be here I know it was
all to get on the I'm curious what about
what about women either at Google or
just that you've heard from on email or
social media or anything else better
agreeing with you are you getting it an
interesting amount of support from women
yeah I'm definitely getting a decent
amount of support from women and I think
the support is generally just based on
your political orientation so
libertarian conservatives are much more
likely to agree with my document than a
progressive is and it depends just sort
of just how libertarian sort of you are
right so you're saying women are allowed
to be libertarian and conservative they
don't just have to be progressive right
there are a controversial statement
fewer women that are a libertarian
though for maybe similar reasons others
so that's kind of interesting so there
are so that's a fact is there are less
women that are libertarian because they
might play into some of these causes but
the ratio is about the same 20 to 80 so
80% of libertarians are about women
mm-hmm and it's just the personality
type of highly logical is more
represented by men and that's the
personality type of libertarians and you
know very individualistic rather than a
more collective mm-hmm a personality now
people are gonna hear that and that's
just so this is so interesting because
it does get to the heart of so many of
the things we talk about here and what
Ben Shapiro says facts don't care about
your feelings you've said a couple
things right there that they feel wrong
in a way like there's some what do you
mean how could that be but but the
evidence
mm that doesn't mean things can't change
and that we all can't evolve differently
and all that but the evidence the facts
in this case basically support what
you're talking about here yeah and I
mean I don't feel like people would
necessarily say that being libertarian
is better than being progressive or
conservative and ER I I think a lot of
progressives that would find defense
with this think that being progressive
is good so and they honestly think that
conservatives are evil so you know it's
they're happy to be like how they are
yeah
okay so now you've done a bunch of these
shows you've gotten your story out there
you've sort of been through the storm
already it sounds like you don't know
exactly what you want to do next
have you been presented with any
interesting opportunities uh-huh I mean
there's definitely I've talked to random
CEOs that were supportive but obviously
many of them didn't want to be publicly
known that they supported me so does
that show that we've sort of lost the
war in a way like we're like we're
winning interesting battles a guy like
you who you know nobody outside of your
world knew a month ago you're you're now
known and you're gaining traction all
that so I see that as a win a battle a
win of a battle but in the war sense
that all these CEOs of companies that
they might want to work with you might
having nothing to do with this they
might just good man this guy's got a
great resume I want to work with this
guy he's a free agent right now but even
that that they they just might be cowed
because they don't want to deal with it
yeah and part of this lawsuit is
potentially trying to push it the other
way because so much of their their
concern is that they're being attacked
so much by these social justice
activists and so if they ever go more to
a rational side on these topics then
they'll just be attacked but you know if
there's ever you know a lawsuit that
says hey you know you can't be you can't
discriminate against conservatives and
you know you can't be just some extreme
left and discriminate and do whatever
you want then maybe they'll finally see
I don't know yeah but you know if
there's only one side happening then
they'll just become more extreme right
it's so interesting to me because as you
said there were several different
diversity groups now I suspect but
please correct me if I'm wrong if there
was a group of pro-life people at Google
would they be allowed to form a group do
you think or how would that group be
treated it's I'm not sure that they
would be able to make a group I think
some people would say oh yeah that makes
people uncomfortable don't do this right
now you obviously would be able to
create a pro-choice group right I
suspect there would be no right that's
that's in line with leftism and
progressivism but the difference between
pro-choice and and pro-life really is
it's a it's always been known as a
political choice it's a choice it's a
but you're saying most likely that group
doesn't then come to be yes so I mean I
know of several anecdotes where someone
came out as pro-life
and then their team just abandoned them
and started just ostracizing them and
there have been events where Planned
Parenthood and some more pro-choice
things were advertising in some event
and someone said hey you know either I
show both sides or let's take politics
out of the workplace mm-hmm and they're
just you know no don't don't talk to us
so there's definitely an asymmetry there
yeah I'm curious because I've mentioned
a little bit lately that with all the
stuff going on with monetization on
YouTube it's hard to feel when I've had
the limited contact I've been able to
get with Google people it's hard to tell
who knows what or where the buck stops
will escalate this will you know send
somebody just submit another form for
this do you think that Google as an
entity has almost become too big it's
become that 1984 monster that that the
bones of it it's sort of crumbling under
its own bones because it was abandoning
biology in the name of biology or
science or reason whatever you want to
use there in the name of social justice
yeah I think definitely there's a lot of
disadvantages to becoming too big
especially you know nothing like this
would have ever happened if it was just
a hundred person company because people
would know me and they would know that
I'm not
some crazy bigoted and if they disagreed
they would just come and talk to me
rather than write some public messages
of how I'm a Nazi and we should all
punch him you know so yeah there's a lot
of miscommunication and just people not
knowing what's happening at Google
there's you know it's common where we
have multiple chat apps and stuff it's
just not really some coordinated actions
yeah it's so interesting because the
idea that they fired you even if let's
go on their side for a sec let's say
that they figured out whatever it is
there's some loophole that they've got
legit cause to fire you it's almost like
that then makes you stronger strengthens
the ideas that they don't want
strengthened as opposed to they could
have just given you a silent death you
know what I mean like they could have
been like this guy wrote this thing they
let the 24-hour news cycle spin out and
then they slowly just degrade your
position or stop giving you things and
eventually most likely you leave right
you just leave on your own accord and
that's that yeah there have been
multiple cases where that happened where
they just you know they try to hurt them
they put them on probation and they just
make life as harmful or just as bad as
possible for these people and that's
what usually happens but they're I think
it was just too much of a PR issue for
them yeah so you had a great tweet a
couple days ago which was that if we
have the sensitivity training then
shouldn't we have sensitivity wait sorry
sorry if we have sensitivity training
then shouldn't we have B sensitivity
training for those who are eager easily
triggered right do you want to say that
better than I just said it just to be
clear did I get across there yeah it's
mostly you know we have so much training
about these microaggressions and oh
someone might find that random thing
offensive and so it just keeps pushing
the line of what we can't say and
there's never any pushback on the other
side and you know I think yeah there are
definitely some people at Google that
are socially awkward and need to be told
that no it's not right to be saying some
of the things that you're saying but we
also need to be telling some pee
like come on just calm down there just
look at what their intention was and
don't get so upset about this yeah
because jokes are now becoming dangerous
and yeah sort of like you know when Bill
Maher said the n-word on his show
whatever you might think of saying that
specific word I don't think anyone in
their right mind think Bill Maher is a
racist and suddenly I literally saw
comedians that I know calling for him to
be fired over a word which is sort of an
odd position to be to be put in all
right so we've got biology we've got
you're sort of we're caught up on where
you are at now do you sense that because
of this that Google is going to do any
sort of introspection or any sort of
reevaluating of these policies I really
thought that they would but at least
according to my friends that are still
working there
they've only doubled down on the
diversity efforts and haven't really
addressed any of the political
discrimination and you know we've
brought up these black lists that people
had before these black lists where
people will just have spreadsheets of
names where these are people that pretty
much are just conservatives or think
differently and they try to sabotage
their work or just don't work for them
at all so so what does that actually
mean
like sabotage their work are you talking
about public people who are creating
using Google services or you talk about
employees employees within Google
they'll uh so there's so many
interdependencies between projects that
I will often have to depend on someone
to help me but if I'm on this blacklist
they'll just ignore my email and you
know if I ask them for a promotion or a
peer review for a performance review
then they'll just give me a bad review
and then once I do get fired because I'm
treated so badly I won't be able to find
work at another company because they
share these black lists ok so that I
mean that's incredible yeah that's quite
revelatory and incredible and obviously
evil and insidious and all of that stuff
do you think then I hope you have an
answer for this but I know this is a
tough one that those listings
for the creators too and the people that
are using Google services because I
don't have to tell you the amount I mean
forgetting monetization aside the amount
of people who generally are Center to
even a little bit right - you can go as
part and then you can go all the way
down at stones but all of those that
people though that group that are out of
the mainstream think that feel like the
algorithm screwing them the monetization
screwing them the subscriber growth the
swing all that stuff do you have any
evidence that any of that is real so I I
don't know if they just have you know
your name in some random file but they
there's other ways for some of these
same things to be happening where they
look for offensive videos and according
to them it's these central or right-wing
videos that are offensive and they never
look at the other side because they're
on the left and so it's through their
own political bias and they may not even
be trying to directly target people but
they just find all of these things and
then they actually feel like removing
these videos or D monetizing them is the
good thing to do mmm because you know if
I disagree with you you must be
misinformed or evil and so you're either
evil or you're telling people wrong
things and
either way just stop doing it yeah I
ventured you right before we started and
this is why I'm doing Tucker tonight I
mean the amount of stuff that they've D
monetized from us I'm sorry from ayaan
Hirsi Ali who I think is one of the
greatest human rights activists on the
face of the earth to then plenty of
conservatives of course ben shapiro and
larry elder and dennis prager but then
also atheists like Michael Shermer
comedians Michael Ian Black and and a
host of other people that I think that
it's not censorship that's what I want
people to understand that that in and of
itself is not censorship but if they are
screwing with the algorithm to not allow
our videos to get out now I don't have
evidence of that but at some point when
you take all of these pieces together
you know extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence it's Carl Sagan
said but you start having to go down
that rabbit hole here right yeah it's
well I think a lot of this is also just
multiple teams
that Google may be doing the same thing
and they may not even understand some of
these algorithms because you know you
just gave them training data and then it
gives you output so it they don't really
understand this neural net or like
what's happening within it mm-hmm and so
it it'll be really hard for even if the
government does try to prosecute them to
show that there's explicit bias within
algorithms and which is so ironic
because for me as a classical liberal
even with some obvious libertarian
leanings I don't really want the
government right to come in and tell
Google what to do but I do think there's
something interesting that it seems to
me Google itself as a public company
they have a fiduciary responsibility
their board to do what's most profitable
and not necessarily what's politically
correct and I suspect that they're doing
things that probably aren't but I just
don't know and again I say that it's
someone I don't want the government
necessarily coming in although I think
there is an interesting argument to be
made that these companies have now
become so big and so important to how we
communicate that they sort of are like
electricity and gas and the rest of that
but that's a that's a whole other topic
altogether you know I want we got a
zillion questions from the audience do
you think in just what we've done here
that did we you think we missed anything
that is really important before we move
on to that portion huh no we can just
move on yeah we did it we did it all
right here's what I do I say it every
time we do this that we're gonna take a
1 minute break then we end up late like
a three minute break we're gonna make
this a 2 minute break and we're gonna
take your questions on patreon we've got
a ton of them already we're gonna also
take questions on super chat on YouTube
I suspect that this video will not be
monetized but c'est la vie all right so
hang on give us give us two minutes just
to freshen up here we didn't drink
though you want to take a sip of water
here let's take a sip of water all right
two minutes and then your question is
with James Moore
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right I think we did it two minutes
there we go
so first up we have a gajillion
questions on patreon here which I'm glad
that my audience is so receptive to what
you're talking about because I think
it's really why people are supporting me
on an alternate platform right now and
helping me do what I'm doing okay so
I'll go with the heavy one first from
patreon any snowden like info that you
can dish out on google sharing our info
with the government etc so at least when
the whole Snowden thing was happening
they denied a lot of it but there are
cases where the government does request
personal information just like a lot of
other companies and Google does give it
out and it's about 40,000 cases per year
or something and you know one thing that
this is linked to too is maybe they will
only give it out to maybe right-wing
extremists and not left-wing extremist I
don't know mm-hmm right we just don't
know what the answer is and I guess that
also depends on what the government's
going for if it's we have a more
left-leaning government or right logo
but well they'll push back on some of
them so maybe they'll push back on the
left-wing extremist I know oh that's
interesting right right right okay James
what alternatives to Google products are
superior and function for us users
I mean Bing isn't that bad I don't know
if it's better but yeah it's hard to say
because I do use mostly Google products
yeah well that's the funny thing I think
there'll be a certain amount of
questions here like people want you to
either throw Google under the bus or the
products under the bus I suspect you you
don't dislike the products and I liked
the company that you were working for
yeah I I don't want to hurt Google I
just want to make Google better yeah
it's so I mean that's exactly how I feel
about YouTube I'm not trying
I want YouTube I want the platform that
I'm on to be the best it can be I want
this thing to grow so we can grow you
know but here we are okay we'll do a
couple Super chats here well this isn't
even a question but just I'm a nice
thanks for having the courage to say
something James to everyone else if you
see something unethical taking place
where you work
do something say something the cost of
saying silent is incalculable
do you have any regrets about doing
dress that I it's hard to really regret
things because I hope at least the world
will be better because I mean Google is
a huge place and it's gonna be our
future so these are huge issues that we
need to solve so you're sort of like
what's his name that was going after
Skynet the Terminator oh yeah oh my god
what's his name I'm blanking everyone in
the comment section John Connor
John John yeah it was John Connor yeah
there you go
let's see we'll go back to patreon in
the time since releasing your memo have
any of the resulting discussions made
him made you change your mind or rethink
any of the conclusions or even it the
way in which you outline your thoughts
that's a great question I I've
definitely had many discussions with
people some that disagreed with me I
haven't really differed on some of the
core things maybe there were some
nuances but I some things like there may
not be explicit sexism happening but
there's just no male typical behavior
which men are just prone and trained to
do throughout their childhood
that is what's rewarded in the workplace
sometimes and that may be an issue that
we need to solve but it's not this
explicit sexism of your woman you can't
do this it's just you know a lot of
competative competition and you know
talking over people is rewarded in some
ways mm-hmm and that hurts a lot of
people both boys and girls that aren't
as assertive right but in and of itself
that generally happens more to women
right because women are less assertive
which is what I was of biological
reasons is your basic argument yeah and
so I would say that you know the these
are they may be predisposed to be a
certain way on average but it's not like
we can't change that in some ways and
you know you could obviously train
your kid to be a certain way and culture
has some effects but you know how much
do we want a really social engineer
things you know right well it's also
like when they'll talk about well men do
a lot of business dealings while playing
golf and not enough women play a couple
you can't force women to play a cop I'm
all for women playing golf if they want
to play golf and I don't think they
should be excluded if they want to play
golf but you can't force them nor would
I want a man to be forced to do whatever
women are doing what if women do let me
see if I get in trouble here what about
women do like golf men for gava let it
go at least what I heard was you know
going to the nail salon going to the
nail salon naturally all right now we
know it's gonna be clicked
can James elaborate on the underground
conservative groups that you mentioned
with Rogen being myself in the computing
industry that sounds terrifying so you
were on Joe Rogan yesterday I didn't
even realize it on 4k so I haven't seen
it yet but but I love Joe he's become a
major ally in in this space and for
helping you know free thinkers and
things like that so what was this about
underground conservative group yeah so
there's some groups within multiple
companies that you know of conservatives
that feel alienated by the dominant
culture and they're not really connected
at the moment because there's so much
there's so many people that want to
infiltrate them and you know record oh
yeah this person said this one thing
that could be construed to be racist and
then get all those people fired or
something mm-hmm and so it it's really a
tricky thing that I don't want to
disclose too much of because of some of
these issues okay I think that's fair a
super chat as a guy studying IT who also
leans conservative libertarian I feel as
if everyone else in the field leans far
left in your experience is that true yet
I far left or libertarian because
libertarian is this very logical type
but they often just and they agree with
a lot of these social issues of just
being you know socially liberal but if
you're socially conservative then you'll
get ostracized often I think at least
for some of these people working for a
smaller company is maybe the better
thing to do that's an interesting piece
of this that at the end of the day if
you want to have as much autonomy over
yourself and your thoughts and all the
things that maybe working at one of
these giant monsters who are trying to
appease ektu everybody is just not the
way to do it yeah or a piece for the mob
right the mob exactly call said do the
strongest political activists have any
special access to our information are
they mostly in lower positions in the
company I think this is particularly
Jersey because it gets the sign that we
talked about before where even when I've
had discussions with you to people I
don't think that anyone necessarily is
outright lying to me but how can we
figure out where things are going up the
chain or where the final decisions are
or where that subtle thing that could
happen in the algorithm is happening or
any of that is there any way to decipher
any of that stuff at least for outsiders
no there's no real way of figuring out
yeah what do you mean outsiders well
just people that aren't employees ok so
someone probably knows something that
you probably don't know yeah there's
definitely some people that know certain
things and but it's pretty distributed
throughout the company right cuz I would
guess I mean it just by if you were a
smart company up to bad [ __ ] and you
wanted to slowly harm certain people on
an algorithm well you wouldn't tell the
people who talked to the creator's about
what you're doing yeah so the people who
are talking them are in LA it's like
plausible deniability right there go no
no we don't do anything and they think
they're being honest but the guy's
higher up are going yeah we're
tightening the screws on the algorithm
so we know that this stuff isn't gonna
get out yeah there's a lot of legal
things that they the PR people or anyone
that discusses it with external people
they can't really discuss it all right
and by the way I asked the YouTube
people to send me a representative I
said anyone I mean you want to be a
janitor just be somebody that works in
that building and of course I got
declined how bad do you think this echo
chamber problem is in other companies or
business spheres like engineering
business legal etc do you think there's
something unique to the Silicon Valley
stuff yeah I think it's probably happens
elsewhere but it is pretty bad and token
Valley particularly because there are so
many of the same tech companies in a
small area and they have so much money
and they dude they just throw it out to
causes that they believe in and they
feel so guilty because
you know there are only 20% women that
it that pushes a lot of these issues so
we sort of hit on this one but but maybe
we can get more your feelings on this do
you think it makes sense to treat
monopolies more like we treat government
institutions that is hold them
accountable so they don't engage in
practices that Google seems to be
engaging how about a market share tax to
prevent great concentration of power
instead of punishing success direct
directly so the basic of crux of the
question is when does is there a time
that the government sort of has to step
in here and I know you how about this
lease of libertarian leanings probably
don't really want that but are we
getting to like some point now where
this may be out of control in a way that
somebody has to step in yet because I
definitely have the leanings of I don't
want the government to be regulating
them at all and I don't know if we have
examples of them actually regulating you
know websites because it's much easier
for someone to just go to a different
website mm-hmm but they have been
getting a little too big in some ways
and Europe has fought back I don't know
if the US will fight back right I mean
and then even when you say that the idea
of the government now regulating things
I don't like that but what I want is
more competition and I guess the
inherent problem is that maybe they
really are monopolies in a certain way
you could take ten of the richest people
on earth and if they had to create a
YouTube alternative they still may not
have enough money because of what
they're dealing against let's see search
for something about James on Google and
they disable the autocomplete for your
name all right really some 1984 stuff
going on there how about that one for
you I guess oh really all right that was
your answer
they definitely looked at what the
autocompletes were and maybe they didn't
like what they were I don't know if
anyone saw what they were before
well I would suspect if they're not
letting it load but it probably was
people saying is right isn't a Nazi not
a white supremacist etcetera we've sort
of it hit this already but do you intend
on staying in public for long I'm sure
the drama is addicting I mean there's
something to be said about that just
that you know people know who you are
now that's pretty cool you get a lot
traction on Twitter and all that stuff
hey there are nice things of you know
being recognized on the street and you
know having random followers on Twitter
but it's definitely draining and it's
not my innate personality so I'm still
trying to figure out what's best for me
yeah you don't strike me as much of a
publicity [ __ ] to be honest with ya
James was of course aware of the PC
climate and culture and why did he write
the memo what did what did you think
would happen now that's sort of
interesting because did you think there
was a chance knowing everything you know
about all this stuff did you think there
was a chance that it was gonna get to
the diversity people and they'd be like
well you know page six he actually kind
of makes a point it's reverse of
everything we've ever said here and
promoted and that would they were gonna
do anything I mean did you think that
that maybe it would get through so I
really thought that they would at least
look at it and think about it rationally
because that's what we do for everything
else at Google you know you see a
problem and then you write a document
the to solve it and then people look at
it make comments and something is done
so we're really big into this type of
you know objective open exchange of
ideas but apparently not for this and
you know actually lists you know ten
different suggestions that we should do
hopefully bill they're actually looking
at that I don't know right don't hold
your breath
okay back to super chat let's see you
and others should form a group similar
to fire the foundation for individual
rights and education but for tech
companies thoughts I love this question
because one of the things that I
actually meant to ask you is all these
organizations Eric Weinstein who I know
you've now met he has said to me a few
times that what these companies need is
that it's one thing okay you want to
have a diversity group and make sure
there's equal opportunity for everyone
and that's great
but what you also need is a free speech
group or a free expression group so
these things sort of work in parallel
together to make sure that the diversity
group isn't stepping on freedom of
expression or the ability for someone
with a contrarian opinion to say
anything do you think that's a good idea
yeah I definitely think that we should
be looking more into this and I've been
talking to the heterodox Academy oh
great where they look a lot about you
know what universities can people freely
exchange ideas and there's a lot of
interest from companies to apply that
same idea to their workplace so because
you know HR is not realizing that hey a
lot of people agree with this and they
feel alienated I wasn't even aware of
that you know maybe we should do
something yeah I'm curious this isn't on
here but we're just bringing it back to
the monetization one more second because
it's just rattling over my head right
now when you hear about this stuff
related to the monetization do you
actually think that the companies that
are selling ads to Google that are that
are putting their ads out there that
they really don't want their ads on all
this stuff or do you think that this is
ideological or is a combination of both
yeah it's hard to say I think there's
some a few very loud voices saying oh
yeah these these videos are horrible and
that may create bad publicity for Disney
or something if they put their ads there
but I I at least hoping that we won't be
dictated by just you know the one really
loud voice you know this is interesting
what do you think about the role of
collective bargaining unions etc and Oh
an at-will employment in tech mmm-hmm I
think definitely you know I'm pretty
libertarian but I think that there are
cases for some of these collective
bargaining and just you know giving more
power to employees because there is a
huge asymmetry in power between
employees and employer it's not as much
of a free-market type thing that we
would like to see and you know I I do
agree that you know even at-will doesn't
mean that they can just fire you for no
reason at all and there are some cases
in the National Labor Relations Board
right now where
people have you know this is a bad
example but they said the n-word to
someone and then they got fired and
that's actually against the law you
can't fire someone for doing that which
is you know maybe we should be able to
but there are limits to what people can
fire you for hmm
super chat if if AT&T listens to your
calls and disconnected your phone when
you said the wrong thing we would be up
in arms the FCC should remove Google's
common carrier status because they
monitor and filter traffic I mean I
think we've sort of danced around that
you have anything any other thoughts on
that I mean it's that I mean this is a
tough spot for for a libertarian I think
yeah it's getting to a point where you
know power is being accumulated and just
a few key players and at some point
we're really going to have to fight back
against that because too much power
whether it's in the government's hand or
a private company isn't good for the
general public this is interesting from
superjet I found that my political views
changed completely when I was on
antidepressants are you aware of any
studies linking far-left political views
and antidepressants that would be
fascinating like fascinating fascinating
you got anything on that so there are
some connections between you know some
drug use and political orientation so
psychedelics for example can increase
your openness long term and openness is
related to progressive or left so you
know that was potentially one of the
reasons they actually banned
psychedelics was that it actually
changed how you voted hmm but I don't
know about antidepressants and
specifically okay keep up the good work
Dave and James if James wants to come up
to Toronto and make $15 an hour you've
got a job waiting for them all right we
got you a job also Dave you pronounce
the word because strange because how do
you say because because because because
because I'm from Long Island suck it up
all right a question for both of you
does does having YouTube Reb help the
content creators i watch with D
monetization or does the money goes
straight to Google
thanks love the show Dave I'll let you
answer that one first all right so you
don't know so well I know that when they
look at our modernization which is quite
horrific these days when I look at the
back end we see a certain amount just
from regular ad plays and that sort of
thing and then we see another number for
YouTube bread I have no idea what that
and how that number is broken down or
anything like that that's all I know but
I know that yes if you have YouTube
bread and you watch this that we're
getting some all right that's all I know
yeah I would at least hope that they
don't give you a smaller percent than
normal but they may just be right but
but do you want to finish that sentence
no I think no one really knows besides
them yeah
after seeing the google attempt to
disable Jordan Peterson's account how
soon do you think Google will begin
cutting off access to average users with
these harmful opinions all right
hopefully they saw how much bad PR the
whole John Peterson thing was for them
that they'll stop doing this type of
stuff do we know what happened there I
mean I remember the day that it happened
but we know what specifically happened
that caused that whole thing so they
claimed that there was some automated
anti spam detection and you know maybe
that was and there were some
contradictions in the story where they
said that there was some human looking
at it but then later they said that
there was no human looking at it I mean
just sounds like such people anti-spam
protection I mean the guy's one of the
most brilliant professors and I think
preeminent thinkers we have in literally
in the world right now the idea that
that's the way these things would be
treated is just it's just ridiculous
what about putting programs like this on
twitch denying Google traffic and income
I would like to see them punished for
this action I mean people are trying to
figure out some other avenues do you
have an alternate avenue for any well I
guess we ask you about the services
before anything else we don't know about
I mean there's twitch dailymotion Vimeo
those are all other video hosting sites
they're just much smaller than YouTube
let's see there's a lot about you know
that there's a lot of these people that
are saying that they're conservative or
libertarian that just feel that they're
they're afraid to talk about things
um in some ways what you relieved not to
work for a company that is so hell-bent
on pushing their agenda because you
don't you strike me as actually kind of
at peace with everything like you don't
I mean I can tell you're you're in it
but do you feel a certain sense of peace
in this craziness I you know I meditate
and I I try to just not regret things in
general but you know I I really wanted
to change Google from the inside rather
than what I'm doing right now
you would rather yeah so you would have
rather had this thing just everything
being equal you would just go back and
have had them listen to some of this
stuff and maybe make it better James I
interned at Google in LA this summer and
watched this debacle unfold from the
inside do you think the unique culture
inside Google meme Jen especially
reinforces progressive dogma by design
or does it arise naturally also did you
write an epitaph it wasn't visible when
I last checked so yeah epitaph is
something that you can write and so it
people can contact you after you leave
and you can give some reasons why you
left or something oh I thought it's much
darker than that somehow I I didn't
write one because so when they called me
and said oh you're fired they shut off
my access completely yeah just like that
yeah have you ever been in any trouble
with Google before no and even one
comment sent HR had at anyone at HR ever
said your work is not good you're no
you're treating women or any other
employee or anything no I had just
gotten promoted so I I got the like
highest performance review possible and
so it it definitely wasn't performance
related oh but there was a first part of
that yeah so the first part being do you
think that the unique culture inside
Google meme Jen especially reinforces
progressivism by design or does it arise
naturally there's it's hard to say I
think of platform like name Jen is only
going to push these mob mentality and
virtue signaling and the head of meme
Jen is was actually very active in
trying to attack mine he at some point
he so
was just a Google Doc he suggested to
just delete at all which would do a
strike through all through all the words
and that was just left there for a while
people couldn't read it like people that
high up in the company shouldn't be
doing stuff like that right right okay
just to remind everyone where are you
there you're over there I just remind
everybody we're taking questions on
patreon and on super chat which we're
with James d'amour for a little longer
super chat Dave welcome back wanted to
say that we I at least donate to you
because you're using our money so well
so it's a 2-way appreciation thank you
for that for my question can James
explain more context around memos and
their usual impact internally that's
anything yeah so and this was sort of
Google Doc it wasn't an email that I
just sent out and so we can you just
take that a little further because I
think there's a certain amount of people
again that think you blasted this partly
you went to whoever was gonna you know
get it to the most eyeballs and all that
but that is simply not what you did all
right he explained earlier yeah it was
just a Google Doc that I shared with
some people and then I put it on the
skeptics list and was like oh what do
you think about you know my views of
Google's I do all ideological echo
chamber and I'm a onto something or am I
in my own echo chamber so yeah there's a
lot of documents at Google that you know
try to fix issues in the culture and I
actually you know modeled this after
some of the other ones that I saw I
don't know if you know the answer to
this one super chat will you join the
people of kekaa Stan and provide your
skills to create an algorithmic weapon
to surpass metal gear I guess I just say
you'll think about I think about you
should Google's machine learning
algorithms be made open source that's
really interesting possibly I it's part
of their intellectual property and
that's how they have an advantage over
other competitors so it's it's hard to
say what they really should do fair
let's see the Department of Labor is
trying to cook up a discriminate rate a
discrimination against women case
against
their only problem is that they don't
have evidence to support the case so
arguably this case was caused in large
part by government over-regulation
because I've been a little out of the
loop the last a little bit I haven't
heard about this do you know anything
about that yeah there's some case of
there saying that there's a pay
disparity between men and women and all
I know is that the internal reports that
they've been doing for like four years
now
have shown that there is no gender
disparity once you control for a
performance which the external you know
a government agency doesn't really know
about our performance reviews in
anything they just know that aggregate
statistics so I don't think they'll
really find anything but right
especially since it's not like
individual managers even get to choose
oh you get to pay it pay this motor and
that it's all by committee and they you
know try to do this control by gender
stuff quote do no evil end quote used to
be Google's motto how does James feel
that Google in and alphabet as a whole
or doing in general and living up to
their former motto yes so I I think that
they still believe in the do no evil
don't be evil thing but it's that the
definition of evil has changed and they
started mandating it both internally and
externally so it's now just if we don't
agree with you then you're evil you know
we don't like your YouTube thing so
we're going to censor it or D monetize
it so there is some people by my
definition of evil yeah
welcome back back David looks like a
month off-duty is some good I have
libertarian leanings but government
still has a place in some areas does it
not the key is to not have too much
power in one place in my opinion we've
discussed this already a couple of times
and I think that's why this story is so
interesting to me too because it puts
our own beliefs and biases up for the
challenge now right we see them you see
a major problem with the company that
again that you like that you wish this
would have helped you don't want the
government to come in and take too much
power and it's a great argument to have
over over all that stuff do you bet any
other thoughts on that well I quickly
yeah no I think we've already covered
that
okay now we're really gonna put you on
the spot super chat how is James
newfound infamy effected his love life
are the liberty minded ladies storming
the d'amour castle yes so my girlfriend
she sort of disagreed on some things but
it's more that she really doesn't want
this to be true that there is some sort
of political bias affecting how we're
seeing these issues I mean we've grown
stronger because of this you know
struggles sometimes bring people
together mm-hmm I mean I have gotten
random messages from women that seem
like me but I haven't really bit on that
at all yeah well for a crazy misogynist
girlfriend stuck with you and you're
getting your hearing from other women
all right let's see oh this is
interesting in your experience at Google
do the witch hunters use their
colleagues social media content against
them should young conservatives and
libertarians in tech stay away from
social media altogether I get this type
of question a lot related to college
kids when I go to schools and they'll
say well can I talk about this now I
want to get good grades I don't want my
professor you know fighting against me
or anything like that yeah I think it
can definitely hurt you if you post
conservative or just other types of
things on social media and you know
we've even seen
I think pecks Dickinson wrote some
things on Twitter and then he got fired
from a CTO position so what you saying
social media can be used against you by
these social justice warriors we got
super chat +1 for rational and
respectful dialogue hashtag real news
all right real news something's real I
can't believe it
the black lists this is super shet are
designed to bully that is disrespect it
works by the bullies the Nazis did the
same thing all right let's put the word
Nazi aside because you're being called
the Nazi which is obviously idiotic but
these the idea of these lists these
secret or it sounds like they're not
even that secret right I mean these are
people admit to having them yeah how
danger
do you think that is I suspect quite
because you were probably hung or you
were probably on every single one of
them yeah they're pretty dangerous and
just the fact that it's socially
acceptable to admit that you have these
and you openly pretty much hate certain
people it's that's us look very slow
yeah is there any evidence that Google
conservatives secretly had lists of
lefties that they won't work with is
there any evidence of those lists
existing I have that either I don't
really know I I think that they're so
angry at just the idea of these black
lists and they see the harm that's
causing but there may be some people
that you know see the tactics used by
the other side and want to use them to
our decentralized platforms like yours
dog org library steam and others the
future of media and you have any
interest in crypto currencies like
Bitcoin I think yeah they definitely
have potential and the more that people
see a centralized power can lead to some
negative consequences the bigger they
will come become what about Bitcoin and
what's the new owner reap Emory p.m.
yeah lilium what the hasn't I know they
were mining it on avatar with that one
the new owner reap em oh I don't know
how Fred yeah yeah what do you make a
cryptocurrency in general mmm they have
potential but it's really hard to say
and there's a lot of disputes even
within the Bitcoin community on exactly
how it should be implemented and that's
why we're seeing multiple of them now so
it's pretty risky but people have made a
lot of money betting on them so yeah I
have liked to Bitcoin I'm just kind of
leaving them there and we'll see what
happens like twelve thousand dollars or
something that twelve thousand dollars
yeah it's it's really grown don't worry
I'm losing enough on YouTube
monetization that it probably all evens
itself out from patron do you think
there's any chance for a pendulum shift
back towards the center in tech and
large companies generally where these
issues can be reasonably debated and
discussed without the immediate social
pariah status and firings or have things
gone so far past that point that the
only viable alternative is for new
companies to be create
again we've sort of hit on this but
that's interesting like do you think
there's a chance but we could even put
Google aside for this one that that this
story the lesson of this story might
help in ways that we can't see right now
yeah I think if there's a chance just
because you know even though there's the
political bias and just natural biases
that are causing some of this there's
also just the financial incentive that
they may have where they see if they
don't you know toe the party line that
they'll get attacked but if there's also
financial incentives to not you know
have these black lists and fire anyone
that disagrees then that'll at least
moderate them in some way any idea of
how far Google is willing to go to
silence viewpoints it doesn't agree with
well we know they fire people anything
else I yeah they're they'll they'll do
some certain things I mean they'll
remove ads from certain web sites
they'll remove YouTube videos they may
push results far from Google search
results I don't know the exact extent it
don't go though yeah
well it's interesting cuz I can see
you're really trying not to throw them
under the bus you're being careful with
your words not to say anything that's
untrue and yet you're sort of given a
little bit of like you're leaving some
crumbs for some of the path to be found
and I think that's what people people
are trying to figure out here which i
think is I think it's a credit to you
let's see I don't think this is a cause
for government intervention I think this
is a symptom of government interference
in society in general and supporting
social justice do you agree that's an
interesting take yeah and that can be I
can definitely be the case because as I
was saying before you know they there's
a lot of people suing for these social
justice causes and at least I've heard
anecdotes of these activists that will
blackmail companies say hire us for
these diversity programs or we'll sue
you and so they're sort of pushing it
and it's only because they could sue and
get the government involved that they're
able to push this agenda yeah and if
people want to know how
bananas this whole thing is I mentioned
to you right before we started I got an
email from a friend of mine who was a
somewhat public person who will not be
named right this moment cuz I don't
think he wants to go public with this
stuff who's in Hollywood in a and he's a
straight white man and basically has
been told by almost everyone in the
industry we're not gonna hire you
anymore like they're flat-out saying it
to him at this point and this is a guy
who has a pretty great
resume and is and it's just screwed
because this lunacy all right super
check great episode Dave shoutout to the
new subreddit called stop being evil
it's dedicated to exposing Google's
censorship and other creepy behavior I
guess have you seen this subreddit yet
oh yes I'm oh yes of it on my subreddit
actually oh you have your own subreddit
how is that what you did the original
read again I was off the grid when you
did this yeah I didn't name AMA on my
sub reddit I didn't really know how to
do it so I I figured I could do it on
this one right because there were some
you know right-wing people that wanted
me to do it on there and I I didn't want
it to be political really I just wanted
to be sort of neutral mm-hmm but you
know you should come over there pretty
friendly you know I saw your self writer
and they seemed it sort of angry I don't
know well I don't want to get into that
they were that wasn't my my own thing
all right yeah it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it seems that the best
way to decentralize the power of large
companies such as Google could be
accomplished by the removal of patent
thoughts this is another interesting one
for for a libertarian yeah pens can
definitely cause the centralization of
power because you know it you only just
gained more and more power as you gain
these patents and their uses tools by
the extremely wealthy companies to
attack competitors so it creates a
barrier to entry definitely I love this
question and I can't believe I didn't
ask it what top-level companies if any
are doing things right in terms of
diversity opinion do you see some
companies doing it right because I'll
promote the hell out of them and I'll
try to work with them and I'll try to do
stuff with them if so alright there are
some companies that have talked to me
and it seems like they're doing the
right thing but I don't know if I should
make them public just because
they talked to me in private right which
think how sort of unfortunate that is
but maybe you could tell me privately
after everything between us but but
hopefully that that shows a little see
that's the thing what this with this
accusation of Nazi alright nonsenses so
they a company has to privately go to
you now you have an interesting
opportunity to help promote them but you
don't even know if they want that help
from you or for me or whoever and that's
it's such a shitty situation it's
interesting to hear James keep using we
to refer to Google being involuntarily
separated from a company you care about
it's difficult to get past it's still I
feel like they're part of my family or
I'm part of their family but I see
myself saying we a lot too I believe
this is what they call the black sheep
of the family with the amount of
informational information that Google
manages do you think that they or some
automated process could attempt some
form of subtle manipulation like
generating echo chambers shadow banding
and even some form of really subtle
blackmail I think your answer to yeah is
yes to this that we just kind of don't
know yeah although I don't know if there
so far as you know targeting specific
users and deciding oh this is someone
that we don't like therefore we're gonna
show them weird stuff but you know a lot
of social networks try to find what your
preferences are just algorithmically and
will show you things that you like so
it's not unique to YouTube for example
to show you videos that you like you
know Facebook is also creating its own
echo chamber so it's a problem in
general fair enough
you mentioned the other day that the
Google Image Search ads are technically
sexist do you know of anything else
similar in google /youtube search and
ads can you can you explain that further
I don't remember saying that
the ads were sexist I mean I think we or
do you know what this person is
referring to do that I didn't hear it so
I and they're they're definitely you
know we look at demographics of the user
and we try to infer that and we use that
to maybe show them different ads so in
that way it might be sexist
and we also look at different companies
like Instagram and Pinterest which were
competitors to image search and we saw a
the majority of those users are women
and the reason was that women are more
open to aesthetics which is another
thing that I mentioned and so we
definitely use some of these things when
we're designing products but we may not
be able or we may not be so open about
discussing them in our diversity
programs this is a total sidebar it's
not on here but as you know I was just
off the grid for a month and I truly I
felt like a million bucks I thought I
cleared my mind in so many ways I felt
my train of thought was better my
attention span was better I was more
attentive to people and my dog just as a
general thing like do you feel we're
just too inundated with this stuff at
this point like as humans and what our
brains have evolved to be what they
biologically are you think is staring at
this thing they might be a problem yeah
I think we're definitely too addicted to
being connected and more just
person-to-person interactions and maybe
interacting with nature can definitely
improve your general happiness fair
enough all right I'm gonna keep keep
doing work in the yard out there okay we
did that one I have people telling me
that enforcing immigration laws is
racist
I don't understand that level of
delusion left seems to have lost its
mind how can I begin to programming the
religion of the left so obviously this
is going to my real house I talk about
this a lot what do you think is a tactic
if you see someone that's buying all of
this stuff yeah it's really hard I think
some of Jonathan heights work is really
good in explaining the ideology behind
the left and right and showing that you
know they disagree but it's not because
conservatives are just racist sexist
bigots it's they have different morals
that they're operating on and those
caused them to see issues differently
and at least you know showing that you
have a different point of view and it's
not just a bigoted point of view that
there's morals of you know
having a law-and-order or something like
that is not necessarily bigoted right
well I think we already got this but do
you have any insight into what's driving
the D monetization of so many YouTube
videos now or did you work in a
completely separate area of Google so we
could just answer that in the context of
your work did here software engineer
what what in the world is that even mean
I had a place on is a gajillion products
yet so I was a coder for image and video
search and so we interacted with YouTube
actually and I interned at YouTube so
I'm interactive then a little bit and
and you know there were a company-wide
meeting so everyone at Google knew some
aspects of it I there D monetization
thing I think that really wrapped up in
the controversy last year where there
were some advertisers that were just
angry about particular videos having
their ads so that was the excuse for
them to start doing a lot of this new
monetization but I don't know how much
of it is a rational response that and
how much of it is just AIA logically
driven at this point do you think they
were waiting for an excuse that even
though they knew it was gonna hurt the
bottom line which as I said before it
could be an issue with shareholders you
know in terms of stock you think they
were just waiting in a way like they got
the call from whoever those I think AT&T
or whoever call you know cancelled the
bulk ads and they were like oh we're
losing money but yeah because we can
finally move on this ideological thing
that we care about yeah it's possible
and you know you mentioned that this is
hurting their bottom line but they've
actually stated when they went public
that we'll do certain things that we see
us right but we'll hurt our bottom line
so they're definitely open to stuff like
that that's interesting I listen I don't
have enough information on what as I
said the fiduciary responsibilities of a
company is to its shareholders but I
think there's some there's just
something interesting to explore there I
it it's very obvious that that is not
what I am an expert in all right in your
opinion should Google as a company be
split up similar to Standard Oil was
split up in the early 20th century I
think we've kind of bounced around that
if you've got anything else let me know
Oh have you done do you know about the
reasoning behind altering the search
results for American inventors the image
results are all people of color and
women and I don't recognize 90% of them
and Benjamin Franklin shows up only on
the first few pages so a bunch of people
have sent this to me is it American
inventors is that the first if you just
searched American inventors when you're
within America then it shows just a lot
of these minority inventors and not some
of the more famous ones even though if
you do the same search in a different
country sometimes in a different
language it'll show some of the more
famous ones
I think someone's that mean I mean
really now so give me some insight and
Wow in the world does that happen no one
has a problem with mine no one but I
certainly don't have a problem and the
average person and 99% of Americans
don't have a problem with a minority
inventor Jorge or a female inventor but
if you're searching inventors you want
to know who the big shots are in this
case I guess most of them happen to be
white at least you know within the
context of American whatever so what is
this yeah I think a lot of it just is
someone complained about oh this wasn't
diverse enough and therefore we need to
change it and so they able to whip it a
little bit and now it's how it is so
it's basically an endless hostage
situation I think is sort of what you
described before that because these
words of racist and bigoted have taken
such meaning that everyone then that's
about to be subjected to it'll be like
yeah I'll screw with the algorithm no
problem we'll put Benjamin Franklin on
the 18th page you know whatever and
we'll forget about them yeah that's
that's scary all right well I think
you've also answered this but what made
motivated you to make such a public
position on a heated topic like this
what made you want to be the test case
you're a braver man than I cheers I mean
I never meant for the document itself to
be public but once it was I felt like I
had sir I had a responsibility to you
know at least show that I'm not some
sort of Nazi white supremacist and how
did that get part of the link now I
understand it but for the average person
watching this
is that where you write this and then
suddenly you're being called all right
and a white supremacist and all that how
do you even see how they do that trick
yet I think that they just there's not
really any logic behind it it's just
they want to smear my name and they say
oh yeah he didn't say this but he
implied it in some way and yeah I they
just do it to hurt people in general of
people whose opinions they disagree with
all right you know what I think we'll do
to humor to more I think you've been
very focused and here and I think I
think to Morris fair because I think a
lot of you know there's a ton of support
for you obviously here and all that
stuff so here we go so this is the best
interview I've seen with James d'amour
and I've seen them all terrific job
fascinating content okay thank you as
I'll still do two more you have a
favorite book or blog that you might
want to send people to or tell people to
read mm-hmm at least about this blank
the blank slate by Steven Pinker was
pretty good mm-hm and I think we're
getting them on the show I've been
working on it oh really yeah that'd be
great we're trying we're trying in your
opinion do you think there will be
practical ramifications for not
promoting or hiring based on merit
meaning that the actual Google software
will be negatively affected this is a
really complex question but I think it's
a good one yeah definitely that could
happen and especially as things get more
and more complicated within Google you
get bigger and bigger systems you need
the best people so so basically you have
these interdependent systems and if
you're not hiring based on merit alone
that one system failing starts other
systems to start feeling I mean it
really could be the the collapse of
something math yeah and you know a lot
of what they do is alienate some of the
really system oriented people like
basically people on the autism spectrum
and those are the people most skilled at
really analyzing these systems and
discovering the rules behind them and
but those are also the people that don't
really understand social situations as
well and that's who they're punishing
with a lot of this unconscious bias type
stuff
which is particularly fascinating
because there's a lot of people that are
on the spectrum in Silicon Valley right
so it's really this like it's a
double-edged sword but it's also like a
really confounding thing for these
people who just want to do good work I
mean to do the thing that they're really
focused on and really passionate about
mm-hmm yeah that's something all right
well I'll ask the last question it will
come from me but thank you guys for
submitting all the questions
it's pretty obvious to me you're gonna
you're gonna find a job you're gonna do
well all that good stuff but I have a
feeling somebody might be out there
watching this right now going I want to
help this guy um sure we can send them
to your Twitter and all that stuff but
you you want to give any kind of cell
job for somebody that's that's out there
looking for somebody with your skill set
or anything
yeah I'm still trying to figure out what
exactly I want to do if they want to
support the lawsuit there is the
researcher that I have but yeah I'm
still personally trying to figure it out
but if anyone really wants to discuss
things just send me a message and
because I'm always going to have
one-on-one conversations with anyone
yeah all right well listen if you've
proven anything to me here is that
you're a humble guy your intentions are
good it seems to me that if you were
provided with evidence that what you
have some of the things that you've said
here we're wrong or misinformed whatever
that you'd be happy to continue that
discussion and if you remain a public
figure I'd be happy to do this again and
if you don't I'd be happy to go for
coffee or for lunch and and I wish you
luck with everything you're doing yeah
thanks
all right well thanks to James d'amour
you can find him on the Twitter did you
have the blue check before this whole
thing happened uh yeah I got it before
this whoa oh no no no I didn't have
Twitter at all before those I still
don't really know how to use it he
wasn't even on Twitter before this
people he's got the blue check it's and
his handles quite appropriate it's fired
for the number four truth so I thanked
James and I will be on Tucker Carlson
tonight probably discussing some of this
stuff and discussing the YouTube
situation and all that and and again as
i will say to tucker tonight and it's
sort of what james said to me he was
talking about these things because he
wanted the company be better that's what
I want YouTube to be and more
parent and all that good stuff so anyway
thanks for watching this and we are live
tomorrow know where we were going to do
Blair White tomorrow but I believe we
are we're doing it on Tuesday there you
go I got a came back there I'm not
making this stuff up alright thank you
guys for watching
[Music]